[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
welcome to fight night flashbacks this
is a very special episode because we're
watching my losses and there's some bad
ones that i haven't seen in years so
it's gonna hurt my feelings but that's
nothing new is it enjoy this reddit so i
got my boya griffin here and he is not a
fight fan so it's really going to hurt
his feelings yeah theo i think uh to
make him feel better uh when things are
going rough you watch my losses so
you've seen these quite
a lot
dude i'll get i'll dude i'll hire a
mexican dude to beat them out of both of
y'all bro fair point all right the first
one is my first last second guys this is
let me let me just set this up this is
immigration fair point
this is the ultimate fighter finale so
my first real fight ever in the ufc i'm
the main event it's at the palms casino
in las vegas
this fight would not get sanctioned
anybody anywhere else because i only
have three fights here's over 30. i just
have a world champion i have one
question though yes so he can't get a
better picture
nah that's like he had to get a guy he
got to get a post fight picture is what
he uses as his uh promotions
this guy played for the grizzlies that's
not the same guy are you talking about
uh bryant bryant reeves big country
bryant reese
oh my god all right vancouver grizzlies
at the time hit it
bro i was so confident going this fight
too
were you yeah i was just like so young
26 man oh my god this guy's burly as
hell too you lost to this burly dude bro
he was a savage
don't don't let the looks fool you man
all right yeah i don't know nothing
about this thanks brother i'll tell you
how it ends
oh man this dude's two months pregnant
that's the thing they call him big
country he doesn't you would think like
a guy he and he's world class at this
time he's writing top ten so you think a
guy like this
you know would be shredder don't let the
looks fool you i mean i just i what do i
know you know what i mean like just i'm
just saying like it looks like he he
came in like i don't need to get in
shape for this fight
that's what's crazy is cardio is crazy
power's crazy he's his hands are fast
he's super athletic he's a black belt on
the ground look at my corner trevor
whitman what are you thinking it did
greg jackson i honestly thought i was so
naive to the situation i was like i'm
gonna steamroll this fat dude so so so
how he looks
came into play in your head right no not
really because we're on ultimate fighter
together so i knew he was a beast but i
just figured like his things jujitsu my
thing was boxing so figure if he's gonna
when he got people down the house it was
over when he got me down i knew i could
get back up you'll see he gets me down i
get right back up and i'm like oh he's
[ __ ]
boy was i wrong
this is also the first time i've really
like he landed you'll see he lands like
a flush right hand and that's the first
time i actually felt of
you really that's the first thing
oh this hurts
cut cut i like this i like seeing this
is what normal ears look like for you i
like it yeah yeah man this is pre yeah
pre colorful pretty beat up oh wow wow
i remember as we're going through this
fight i remember looking in the stands
for the first time and there's t ortiz
there i saw hulk hogan i remember them i
said holy [ __ ] that's hulk hogan what
did he say to you right there he said
good luck brother
ooh he's one of those yeah so he's in
your head already yeah
understand what roy say the thing is him
and i were friends that's what makes us
shitty
and i was too nice to him and the
weigh-ins i i really learned my lesson
there oh so so you because you let your
guard down like yeah so he has some
gamesmanship going on he's experienced
oh here we go
sticking to the jab your boy's quick
look at that jab look at the speed son
from a young bee show oh wow yeah man
moving you got in there you got two good
hits in already that jab popping daddy
i'm tan did i go tanning bag yes i did
eric yes i did dude
oh see that there i'm just
this just an experience here and he has
a granite channel this is like a street
brawl yeah he has a granite chin i
thought i could get him out of there
look he does get me down
and that's worst case scenario here
because we worked all camp not getting
taken down
take something oh that's got to hurt oh
my god no you got a 206 pound black belt
on top his thing was is he giving you a
hickey right here
his thing was he would get the side
control and call it the crucifix where
you'd pin your arm and then he would
elbow you and win the fight so i knew
that was his go-to so you'll see him try
to pass right now into side control
right now he's just establishing control
when like not letting me see him see how
he's getting that and then he'll move to
the other side
his top game he was a mo so heavy nope
and nobody nobody on the show got out of
this but how long do they let this go
like well since he's advancing and like
trying to better his position he's not
stalling here okay see how he's going
for submissions and [ __ ] though which is
so that's so offensive like you're not
gonna damn you losing bruh i know y'all
you haven't seen this still
i've seen it
see he's in sight control now that's all
he wants
so his next game was also kung fu panda
now look at this no no one in the house
is that leg mcmuffin baby damn no one in
the house has been able to get up when
he gets into the side control watch your
boy here be cool watch your boy he's
very heavy at the time i'm like a
purplish belt what are you thinking
right here
i just got to get up man just got to get
up
even then i'm calm cool collected he had
his elbow in your junk mm-hmm is that
legal
look at this your boy got up oh wow
now i'm like oh you [ __ ] now dog damn
your neck looks long bro yeah i got that
long neck like your cousin
oof
i just can't stop looking at this do you
see that see the right hand there
here we go this is just a lot
oh my god
see i should have backed off a little
bit your boy is so aggressive yeah why
are you still yeah you really you see
that see that right hand that i was like
oh my face is all warm and cold oh and
it got really hot and like oh that hurt
oh did that give you pause right there
yep i was like i can't do that again and
then i hear his corner go double jab
right hand and that's exactly what he
did
oh my god oh i'm noticing i do see a
considerable difference in what you're
doing right now mm-hmm like now you're
you're more defensive right now right
yeah
is that a mistake well he has all the
power like i should have been smart
about it more calculated i was just full
of piss and vinegar man i thought i was
going to run through them just a young
kid
just a young
if you were in the if you were in this
guy's corner right now what would you be
saying right now exactly what they said
double jab right hand and you're going
to knock them out and that's what
happens here see that one oh i was like
damn that hurt
that was the first time i was like
that's the first like real hit
oh my god i was a kid i was i remember
thinking man you got to give it to you
stan you're standing your ground after
after a hit like that you're not backing
off yeah after i only have five fives be
cool everybody okay all right all right
you know what i'm saying yeah i just now
he does go on to do great things too so
it's not like i lost to some schmuck roy
nelson's a hall of famer yeah i got you
i mean we're not see that left
oh yeah i've seen this in 10 years yeah
this he seems to be like he's measuring
you up that was another great hit that
was a flush hit to the face the jab's
popping boom right there
behind the air oh behind the air oh my
behind the air oh my god that's why i
wanted you here can we oh my god can we
replay it can we go
jesus christ like
oh man now you see like this dude is
girthy as hell and he got a flush hit oh
when he rubbed his belly that's a
signature move
that's force griffin right there oh no
and he became the ultimate fighter
champion
yep now i still earned a contract so i
still get another fight
oh my god
there's rashad he was my head coach he's
disappointed yeah now what's interesting
about this is when i'm leaving the cave
that's joe silly's a real piece of [ __ ]
but as i'm leaving the octagon the
double jab right here i turn
right
so it's not a chin issue there it's the
back of the frame
when you're down come on man he's not
even looking part of the guy's passed
out are you just going to hit him part
of the game
part of the game now connecting [ __ ]
harder all right now when i was leaving
the octagon look how mad i am when we
were leaving the octagon some fans
started talking [ __ ] to me my brother
scaled
up into the stands he got in a fight and
got arrested oh wow let's take a little
break from chat with eric griffin
watching me get destroyed in some of my
ufc fights you know what i'll take this
break because i can i'm getting beat up
watching myself get beat up and inside
by heart is getting beat up living you
learn
anyway uh listen i use kratom to fire up
my brain it's my limitless pill any show
you see that i do whether it's food
truck fight night flashbacks king the
sting in the wing fighter and the kid on
stage touring the trash panda tour which
i am coming to frick in portland june
9th through the 11th and i'm also in san
francisco i'm in san diego it's the
summer tour baby but every time you see
me on stage
fellas mainly fellows some ladies mainly
fellas every time you see me on stage
your boys on kratom but not just any
kratom it has to be the best all-natural
kratom on the planet i'm talking about
happy hippo that's right happy hippo the
kratom is the wild west out there so you
got to use a kratom that you trust that
you can depend on that's why i only use
happy hippo and if you visit happyhippo
herbal.com use promo code sickboy that's
happyhippoherbles.com use promo code
thick boy for 20 off for life you can
use that code as many times as you want
go nuts be the smartest guy in the room
you're welcome go nuts visit
happyhippoherbles.com use promo code
stickboy for 20 off for life you're
welcome now let's get back to me getting
my ass kicked with eric griffin no kate
okay okay so what middle knowledge i
have let me ask you this
when you look back on that
that what he did wasn't his specialty
right his well
that right hand became his specialty
i understand but like that's not what
you necessarily were expecting no from
him i thought on the feed i was gonna
destroy him i was like if he beats me
it's gonna be you know laying prey or
submission so so the fact that he beat
you at your game is really the hard part
yeah yeah i guess i could see that now
you're the boxer and he hit you with uh
i was going glove champ and i had
knockouts coming into it you know he
didn't so
it was heartbreaking
learn my lesson there go on uh after
that fight i go on and i win four fights
i go on a streak i tear the ufc up go on
four fights i beat murko crow cop and
then they go cool man what do you want
next i go i want big nog in brazil they
go you sure you don't want to do in like
vegas or california oh nope i want to go
to his hometown beat the [ __ ] out of
them they okay let's make it happen so
they go back to ufc it's this huge ufc
brazil card
and the thing about this is i again just
young cocky kid and i thought i'm gonna
start this old man i'm gonna starch this
dude and you were feeling yourself after
these four fights you did right i
thought it was untouchable but here's
something else too so in the ufc it's
like
it's unusual for someone to say to be
20-0 like that doesn't happen unless
you're jon jones who's just a complete
freak right so then most people have
like two three four losses for your
record and it doesn't it doesn't
necessarily tarnish no that's the
difference between mma and boxing
because in mma if you're
20 and oh you're not fighting good
people there's no way you can get to the
heavyweight division and just go
undefeated and not have any blemishes so
what is your record at this point right
now uh there let's say so let's say they
don't so count the ultimate fighter
slide be uh eight and one and by time so
eight so you're nine and one uh ten and
one eleven one two so here i'm 12 and
one okay so then i totally get then why
you really are confident going into this
fight now let me tell you something
about brazil so
again i'm not throwing any shade on
brazilians nothing like that not like
andrew elise coach i'm not saying that
they backed the vans up into my locker
room so they got me there but i was i
didn't fight to almost nine o'clock at
night they got me at 3 p.m which is
unheard of you don't want to be in
locker room that long imagine if you had
a show right and you're going on stage
at eight they got you there at 4 pm yeah
that would be terrible horrible so
you're back there just chilling i fall
asleep and then my coach is like man we
don't feel good all of them like we
don't feel good i'm like what and i was
like i don't feel great either we
realized that they left the vans running
so the the fumes from the van were going
into my just my locker room man
just saying
kind of weird here's the other thing too
brazil fantastic
was out there for a week before the
fight and then i stayed because i
thought i was gonna start to him i
stayed eight days after my family and
friends the darkest eight days in my
life walk around brazil room be like oh
taking picture [ __ ] my eyes like all
[ __ ] up go ahead hit
it what's this guy's specialty going in
though he's good at everything okay he
he this would be this would be the
equivalent of fighting michael jordan in
chicago oh my god tom cruise in brazil
okay so what are you what's your
strategy going in there what are you
good at i'm boxing i'm going to knock it
down still once again boxing
because
so coming up before this
i knocked out mercury 9 in 164 247
[ __ ] i'm 244 now son
oh you were ready look at this
yeah that was an intense crowd now
they're also saying portuguese as i'm
walking to the ocean i'm gonna die which
was very endearing
look at his record 32 and six god damn
two
six three 243
i was a big favorite in this one this
guy looks like one of those like that
the mob sends you know what i'm saying
you know like you got to get some money
you know you didn't pay your bill this
is the dude they send that's what he
looks like yes now he has that big scar
because when he's a kid he got ran over
by a bus that's how tough this [ __ ]
guy is
so that's cool so you fighting the bus
dude yeah man
you'll see i hit him with an uppercut
and rock him it is filthy but then you
know
but it didn't do nothing to him but make
him mad yeah man
all you did was hype him up yep
i couldn't eat the brazilian food i
trusted this one family um that would
make me food because they said they
would tarnish my food again you're
fighting michael jordan chicago
so he's trying to get me to the ground
because he's jiu jitsu is world class so
that ain't happening daddy
good head placement there i felt like i
was stronger than him i felt like i was
stronger than roy too
but he doesn't look like you're stronger
than him just from looking
yeah from straight apparently yeah yeah
well even even what was happening right
there but i remember i hit him with this
uppercut ooh doggy you'll see it
okay jab
he keeps trying to take me down not
happening sir not happening i'd rather
get knocked out on live tv yeah you got
a good lower
your your your what do you call that
your lower body strength
my takedown defense was pretty solid
solid man
another little fact for you if i won
this fight i was probably gonna get
brock lesnar next so i knew that going
into it so that's cool so you are ready
yeah you the chance that brock lesnar is
like fighting conor mcgregor back then
it was a big big payday
boom did you hit him that one i missed
okay
but you're making noises like i'm
missing something yeah
that one i missed
i thought that was it and it wasn't
he walks you down lands his [ __ ]
nasty right hand right see he's wobbled
he's a little he's wobbled there and
tries he tries engaging because he's
wobbled i'm like oh i got this old dude
come on daddy is he saying anything to
you right here no hell no he's the
nicest guy though the nicest guy
oh he's got like a weird mark on his
back is that from the bus injury yeah
that's the bus injury jesus christ
he's a twin brother who's also world
class too little nog he's big nog
but yeah that's the first time i've seen
you kick i don't throw kicks yeah but oh
yeah that kick i don't know why i'm
doing what is this kickball what are you
doing that charlie brown kick yeah you
looking for slowly rollies right there
yeah i wish i didn't do that yeah
face a little peppered up too i'm like i
got this old man dude yeah you feeling
good right here in this moment
yeah my cardio is on point i keep
throwing these weird kids yeah what's up
with these
it feels like you're dancing oh i like
that little move you try does that feel
like a street that looked like a street
fighter movie yep i worked with phil
nurse on that that was a combo he sees
that he lands there which it ain't good
oh you were you feeling that one uh i
was like uh yeah cause you seem to be
more defensive right now as opposed to
being aggressive like you see that
uppercut oh see that oh yeah now he's on
queer street dog oh so i don't know if
he can still say that but he's a little
wobble he's wobbling i thought he'd get
him out of there that's why he's trying
to get me down
and then he's just a fighters fighter
man oh yeah he
would jab right hand against that cage
that was your best effort right there
and he he overcame it yep
again as a young kid like i wish
somebody was like hey dude you're gonna
hurt him be patient
think about this is gonna go all three
rounds he's impossible to get out of
there okay but i was just you know young
and immature and
boom oh oh okay that's it you're you're
feeling it okay you're done
[Laughter]
oh man
oh no
oh no mike oh man that's a tough one man
oof oof what are you telling the ref
right there get me the [ __ ] out of here
yes i was saying don't let me die don't
don't let the crowd pick me apart oh
does that is that what happens here they
just throw you into the crowd hill is
gnarly some some this old fighter named
paulo filo tried fighting me when i'm
walking back to the uh
yeah as if you as if you getting beat
isn't bad like you're they keep you beat
you got you got beat here's why it's
hard why are they trying to kill you now
you see that flag that he's doing so
that flag's a soccer oh
yeah that's a bad idea man yeah be a be
cool huh maybe cool all right you saw it
i know
but my god
that was vicious
it was tough to pay the bills back then
dude oh man hell yeah it's tough to pay
the bills the toughest some would say so
okay i have to ask in this moment right
here right here okay so
he he gets the jab and the right yep and
now he's just like he got me wobbled yep
is this this point you just go i i can't
i gotta get out of here no i'm not
feeling anything i don't i'm concussed
already and it's just
okay okay so you didn't just drop on you
i felt like you dropped on your own like
okay hell no
my body shut off here's what
here's what's interesting is that flag
that he's flying is a i think a
brazilian soccer club the night before
my coach who speaks portuguese um sat
down with these two dudes in a suit and
he's whispering and he goes hey when you
knock out they're so sure you're gonna
knock out noguera when you knock them
out we put on this jersey it's the rival
team that he represents i know because
soccer is huge out there you don't give
a [ __ ] how much it was like 80k in cash
80k which at the time is yes
all the money in the world yeah so i'm
like [ __ ] yeah i'll do that
so these two henchmen in tuxedos work
for you know the brazilian mafia
knock on my door i answer it they go
good luck they put the money into the
the hotel safe safe and they go once you
knock them out we're going to call you
and give you the code so you can get
your money but if you lose we're coming
back and getting the money all right all
right whatever man i'm gonna knock this
dude out
didn't go my way
back in the locker room that night cry
my eyes out concussed
two hands man walking go sorry for your
loss
take the [ __ ] 80 grand cash walk out
and then he turns around he turns he
turns around goes you can keep the
jersey oh
my dad has the jersey framed in his
basement can i say something hot it
would have been even worse if they were
like and we need the jersey
can we get the jersey and i'm wearing
they're going i just hate to do this can
we like no mine's do you mind taking
that off like that's our team dude
you're a loser take that off i gotta say
again like here's another fight
where it was a boxing situation that got
you mm-hmm
yeah here's the thing like this like i
was a cheat code in the ufc so
i i
excelled so fast and it's like comedy
like you can only get you have to have
experience you have to have stage time
so you have to have octagon time and so
like big dog has seen the the athletic
kid with good boxing like
that doesn't scare him like he knows he
might get wobbled and then fight through
it and beat me
you know so i was a cheat code and then
eventually you're going to run into
these veterans who are like [ __ ] please
you've seen an athletic kid who can
punch man but it's like what happened
caught up with me i know but it seems
like but it seems like they
are going they they beat you at your
game as opposed to like whatever they're
grinding i know dude
is that is that the hardest thing when
you look back and be like i should have
been a better defensive
yeah should have been so great
he hit me with a jab and a right hook
like a movie i know so so i lose no gear
worse i'm in the darkest place of my
life how many fights after that this is
the next fight they go oh cool shabby
lester nogueira here's another guy with
40 fights here's ben rothwell who's
impossible to finish i go again arrogant
cocky my management probably should be
like hey let's take an easier fight i'll
go ben rothwell i'll destroy this dude
give me ben rothwell hit it
so you're still super confident at in
yourself after
because in five fights now you're two in
four or six fights you're two and four
i lost that one so i lied no no
i won four and then i lost no gear so
i've won four out of five and this is
the sixth fight okay
against this no no but you're a monster
but it's two losses now though i'm
saying in in in six fights because you
lost oh cause roy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so i lost to roy won four lost
no one so i've won four out of six at
this point so you've won four out of six
but the two very veteran
and here's another one the and this this
guy's the most veteran okay like he has
all the fights he just stopped fighting
like last week nice fighting bare
knuckle box now what is it in you at
this point after you lost the last fight
to go into this fight thinking now this
is the one i'm really gonna do just i
guess confidence like i believe in
myself but then also during this time
i'm one foot in one foot out got you
even with the merco cro cop fight i'm
one foot in one foot out he's yeah
now you'll see i touch the leg i throw a
spinning back elbow and rock him the
game plan was to take your time on this
guy and i the inexperience i rush in
you'll see
you'll see
show me another [ __ ] six four two and
forty five pound dude that could pull
this move off watch this watch this god
i pretend i'm taking him down and i
throw a spinning elbow jon jones style
that's who i got it from shout out to
jon jones oh this guy's menacing oh look
at him this guy is menacing that shape
he's ever been not
i am not looking forward to this this
guy you're not mad at the tight shorts
you're tight shorts yeah
yeah what's going on you like the ring
did you bicycle here yeah for this fight
big boy bike club oh okay good good box
that was uh i saw the boxing hit
oh he's strong he's strong i mean he got
you down on your knee just right yeah
oh oh [ __ ] um so it's one minute into
the goddamn fight and the plan was to
take him to the decision the whole game
plan was to take him so you are oh
wobble number with a uh flying with a
back elbow now look at me look i i'm
just
this is and he rocks me he rocks me i
was about to say
oh man
i was just about to say
you've made this mistake three times now
inexperienced dude three times i know
dude you get what you consider is a good
hit in and then you're going when you
rush in for the kill heartbreaking
i you know who i blame with this i blame
the trainers and your coach and your
people man yeah i wish i had someone in
my air who's like dude chill yeah you
needed like somebody really experienced
to like hold you back i agree
because that because that was like you
got the good hit and you were in the
distance now
i want to oh they don't show it but he's
rocked here so i'm just going haywire
and he hits me with boom that hits me
behind the air again oh wow that didn't
even look like it was not
i don't know why they don't show my
spinning elbow
that's the highlight
[Laughter]
show me a heavyweight who's pulled that
off man
yeah man but nobody wants to see the
basket the person hit you know right
before the other team hit the game
winner
yo man show that layup i hit
[Laughter]
you're not lying
i'll edit it in right now
[Laughter]
here's the thing though did the thing
though it's like i need to see how this
oh that didn't even seem like that big
of a hit right behind the air is that
wow
so what
what could you have done differently
there in terms of like protection
not just go in like wild and reckless i
i would have rocked them and sat back my
yeah [ __ ] and then take jab back to the
jab maybe maybe instead of rushing i
would have taken him down and you'll see
i do learn from that because the next
fight after this they gave me levar
johnson at the time it was like the most
take down the heavyweight division i
take him down like 12 times and then the
next fight i get matt matrione and i
take i'm good we're going to keep going
man i want to [ __ ] i want to die
just one minute i want to see if you
learn your lesson in this one no i don't
how many how many fights
when is this fight this is my the last
fight i've ever had okay but i'm saying
oh so you've fought many times since
that last fight since that time i fought
uh twice oh i had two so i lost that one
two losses that have two wins in a row
and then they give me travis brown oh
jesus christ like what
this is this is you you were mismanaged
hold on but but look at this look look
at the back you see the firing i have
the podcast on my on my let's see the
podcast oh
so you are not watching this
yeah and i walked in with abby kenny
fight club finally kid shirt that i
designed myself uh
so he's a minus 360 favorite jesus i'm
coming off a submission win in toronto
this guy is six six two forty three
sixteen and two dude he's number three
heavyweight in the world
i'm at the time i'm not really fight up
that's what i'm saying you know what
you know what this is like when i used
to watch the wwf and then it'll be like
you know the ultimate like the the
internet continental champion would
fight like whatever the weekly loser
just for saturday morning
i mean i wish you didn't call me the
weekly loser but what i'm saying this
guy is 16 and two
number three in the world i'm not even
right you just lost three fights well
i'm coming off two wins in a row still
in totality yeah it's only seven fights
and you lost three of them yeah and they
and they throw you like this is him
tuning up for a big fight yeah oh
correct he went on to fight i think
verdum after this or something
no he lost
so you didn't even tune him up good
say this is like this is a lost loss for
everybody involved oh man i'm really
upset with your people this is the one
fight besides the roy nelson this was
the one fight i couldn't wait to get out
of here i i did not want to be in here i
mean this is the one if i was like god
damn i don't wanna do this i remember
looking like he's so [ __ ] big can i
tell you something this guy is a
combination of all the guys that you
fought
yes he's the most in shape he's the
biggest he looks the strongest
definitely the most athletic you play
college basketball yeah he looks
athletic as hell like oh man
okay and you you i can i tell you
something you're completely different in
this fight than you are in the other
fights a little more passive passive
this is total defensive you know
oh man look at the kick almost got you
in the head can you believe i used to do
this
i don't even know why you did this i
don't either i don't know why you did
this thank you for going into stand-up
and podcasting because this is bro look
at the fighting kid patch on my shorts
yeah you were already you were knee-deep
in oh yeah man you could tell
this is oh man this guy's
now you know what's instrument trash
brown really nice guy really good person
he's married to ronda rousey and they
have a baby wow that baby is gonna take
over the world if she or he wants to
fight i don't know if it's a boy or girl
but either way that that baby genetics
are not hopefully they don't want their
kid to go into fighting
i don't want my kids to my kid excels in
[ __ ] so i'm like that's it buddy yeah
you know he's like you know he's gonna
follow him he's gonna want to do it i
don't think ufc fighters grew up in
calabasas california
you know the boxing has gone to like you
know a lot of the russians are good
because they're the ones struggling
that's all they have to get
boxing's about struggling okay i do go
to get him down and i came in with a
[ __ ] up neck and then he sprawls his
hips were so good so i get him oh you
got him down
i look at that look on your face is just
like please oh just come please
bro
please for the love of god his butt
right here just ah but then he he does
something where he sprawls and he i
landed on my man he just he just picked
both of you up yep
i should have jumped right to that good
just look how strong this guy is yeah
the strong eric oh my god he's like
look at him he's she's just gonna like
unhook you like get off of me
get off of me marry him
hey you brought me here i know you you
for this reason
i'm just i i just didn't think i'd be so
sad watching this i didn't know why you
were doing this when i look at it we
have blended some wins in fellas
yeah but
but he he does sprawl again and it it uh
it
killed i have a c7 or what the [ __ ] you
call it when if you do the mri it's just
black
oh no hit me with an uppercut oh yeah
oh you oh and now i turn here and in my
head i'm thinking stop the fight but
you'll see i act like i'm upset that
they stopped it but inside i'm like
thank god because i'm never fine again
and in the locker room i told my team i
said i'm done man they went all right
just do this one then you're done i went
i'm done this is it no more
oh okay you're just like
you're right here it's like you're
fighting like a little kid you know
you're just like get off me no i'm
fighting like get off no i'm fighting
like a chick on worldstar
you're just like stop it stop it stop it
mom stop i'm like mom
and my mom was herb dean that night yeah
oh my god you're just like stop
right now you should be whispering come
on man
you got me stop this come on come on
don't do this i gotta get out of here
oh he's got your arm yeah oh [ __ ] do
whatever he's in mount and then i turn
and i'm like just stop the [ __ ] fight
see i'm covering up yeah
you're like why is this still going yeah
in my head i'm like just stop the fight
because you're such a big guy and he's
like
oh oh this is just disrespectful
right here i'm talking the ref going i'm
okay don't stop the fight inside man
dear god stop the fight that's the movie
i think we ought to do this this is the
move they do in prison right when a
newbie comes in you know what i mean
fight back there there's 20 seconds left
now in hindsight if i did want to
continue my career i'd be very upset
that they stopped it and i pretend
you'll see my acting chops after this
get ready so i'm sitting here there's
come on my mother is sake is he even
hitting you no he's not going to hit me
hard now watch this i get mad i go what
are you kidding me
yeah
what did you say to him right there
i forget he was cool afterwards he
probably knew
he was cool you think he knew knew what
you think he knew that you weren't
giving it like
i don't know i don't know again he did
man at the number three in the world at
in his prime you're talking about oh
[ __ ] and that's his prime dude he goes
on to some wild [ __ ] he had he had
champion written all oh
that uppercut got me that uppercut got
me another another boxing loss oh my god
brendan oof
oof i appreciate you doing this
just oh man
whoo
wow
oh yeah this is what he is yeah we can
stop it he's just toying with you right
now he's really beating me up yeah man
he's just humping your
you know it goes in there this guy he's
just on you like you know i believe i
can fly
oh well
here we are man yeah you're glad you're
gonna do the frame crawl through some
[ __ ] to get here you're my morgan
freeman oh man
get busy living busy living
well that's the worst episode ever of
flashback fight nights and we are so
proud that brendan has moved on from
that um go watch the special
yeah go yeah if you feel bad for me go
watch the special the green girl poppy
on youtube right now we're about to hit
a million so life ain't bad yeah love
you brother share it
a please bit of work minute don't scare
us i get up i go hard like i'm george
harris make plays break lanes push
weight break chains go hard kick ass
take names